America Revere's Justin as the greatest
of all time
Justin had this uncanny ability to play
anything and everybody was trying to
beat him
[Applause]
[Music]
justin wong was born on November 15th
1985 in New York City to an immigrant
family he never knew his mother and his
father was always working leaving his
grandmother to raise him from a young
age
Justin was instilled with a strong work
ethic his grandmother always told him to
get a good job so he could take care of
himself in the future so he did he went
to school and eventually started working
part time always trying to stay
independent and self-sufficient and when
he wasn't working most of his free time
was spent at the Chinatown Fair arcade
my grandma used to take me to the local
arcade called Chinatown Fair and you
know she took me there it gave me $2 to
play Street Fighter until I lose
Chinatown fair would eventually become
known as the mecca of the East Coast
fighting game scene but back then it was
just a place where the strongest players
in New York hung out and Justin saw the
arcade as a chance to make friends so he
started grinding fighting games to earn
the respect of his peers when you're in
school you want to be like the cool kid
are like do you know like or do they say
like the Alpha so I wanted to like just
be good with them because then they will
spend more time with me because I was
like very lonely when I was a kid so I
was like damn it this is like my way to
break through and make friends in no
time Justin had earned the reputation
among the arcades best players actually
made friends at the Chinatown fair with
like all the like the players that went
to terminus before I even knew what
tournaments were like Arturo Sanchez
Eddie Lee Josh McCall like all those
guys were playing like Morris Capcom my
competitively Justin lost almost every
game he played against the pros but they
wanted to help him out he was young not
even 15 at the time and Justin always
strive to be the best his first shot at
glory came when Marvel vs. Capcom 2 came
out in 2000 if everyone's still learning
the ins and outs of the game
Justin was determined to become the best
mvc2 player in New York I actually said
one tomorrow's guy come to came out like
if tomorrow's check him - ever came out
I would be the best in this game
Justin dominated Chinatown Ferry and
between 2001 and 2003 he won every
single MVC - tournament he bender he
also won MVC - at b5 in 2001 the
tournament that would become Eva and
went on to win MVC - at every evo until
2005 as a kid it never really came to my
mind that I was unstoppable my whole
goal was just like to always play and
just like beat down my friend early on
the East Coast fighting game community
had a rallied behind Justin as their
first champion since fighting game
legend Eddie Lee Justin bodied the West
Coast marble scene and ushered in a new
era of East Coast dominance he was
always just completely dominant in that
game and he did it by picking really
strong characters and he did the same
thing in other games third strikes he
gets to whatever you played he played
the really strong characters and he just
had good enough fundamentals this tech
was never really good he just had really
great strategy and reactions and all the
things that you need other than the you
know exploitation of the game agile
Justin played a slow-paced defensive
style that was seen as boring not only
that he had this miraculous ability to
turn around the most dire matches and
come out with a win
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
people started calling that comeback
potential but as effective as Justin's
turtle style of play was to do the ire
of the community
including his fellow East Coasters he
was the enemy he was the bad guy right
he was the guy that you wanted to see
lose at NBC too because he kept winning
Justin kept playing Marvel too but he
began playing other games and
tournaments as well in Evo 2004 Street
Fighter 3 third strike event he was on
the losing end of the now iconic Daigo
parenthood and though he placed third
that moment made him even more famous
that was definitely my greatest loss
because I never I never like I was like
wow like I can't believe Daigo parried
it but there's also was my greatest loss
just because it revolutionized fighting
in general because when that happened
everyone started playing fighting it
more seriously again just in place
second in 3s at Evo 2005 and 2008 all
while placing top 8 in both marvel 2 and
Capcom vs. SNK 2 in 2009 though the fgc
changed forever
the worldwide release of Street Fighter
4 breathed new life into the scene and
gave Justin Wong yet another chance to
dominate when he first found out about
game stops National Street Fighter 4
championship justin was working a
dead-end job at bayon clusters in early
2009 justin went on to win the u.s.
championship
then beat Japan and Korea's champions
before facing off against Daigo Umehara
he may have lost but this time the crowd
was on his side
in Marvel Justin was the villain the
defensive boring player that everyone
wanted to see go down but in Street
Fighter he was America's champion facing
off against Japan's beast the biggest
moment for Justin was 2009 grand finals
evolution when he went up against I go
because one they're the two guys from
the infamous tiger Perry video and so
now all of a sudden they're rematch that
grand finals for the first year of
Street Fighter 4 are you kidding right
like it's like amazing and then he kind
of became the hero in a way because
people wanted the u.s. to win see Justin
do some damage guy goes here to play
goes all over him all right oh there's
the brawl it's gonna break down he's
gonna go for all
[Applause]
after winning the US national
championship Justin moved down to
California during the week justin worked
at the now-famous Family Fun Center
arcade and used the money he earned to
go to tournaments on the weekend but
playing in California put him in front
of the bargaining eSports scene within a
year of moving out west
Jess Lee was signed by Evil Geniuses
which let him travel to even more
tournaments you know he was one of the
first American fighting game players to
be sponsored by like a really legit
major eSports team he's a great
ambassador to just a really nice guy and
so whenever he has a chance to meet
people from different scenes I think he
does a really good job at representing
us he placed first at World Cyber Games
fort at SoCal regionals ninth at Evo
2010 and seventh at Canada Cup 2010
eventually Justin got an office job at
Nexon then snail games and later and
video but all the while he was still
competing still traveling and entering
tournaments every weekend nearly Friday
night leave Friday night get there
Saturday morning play Saturday morning
leave Monday morning and go back to work
Justin Wang didn't take vacations he
went to tournaments but in 2011 a game
came out that completely changed the
course of his career
Justin was good at Street Fighter but he
was a Marvel legend and Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 gave him a shot at redemption
he immediately went for an in-your-face
aggressive team to distance himself from
the team that made him a villain an MVC
to the first boys night fights like the
Tuesday game comes out Wednesday
Wednesday fights I pick Wolverine strong
feeling you know a lot of people told
him to move away from Wolverine storm
Akuma but he didn't want it he wanted to
win his way and he's a good enough
player that he did that in 2011 Justin's
Street Fighter 4 results slip but his
Marvel results were incredible that's
the pressure that you feel when you
fight Justin walk I think and I don't
know like what you're doing is not
enough you have to do something crazy I
don't he didn't place below top eight in
any MVC 3 tournament that he entered
between the game's launch and March 2014
in that time though Justin developed
something of an Evo curse he was always
one of the best players in Marvel going
into Evo but he could never take home
any combo we'll be right here
[Applause]
evolution 2013 champion it was at Evo
2014 that Justin finally exercised that
demon in the winners finals Justin made
an unbelievable comeback against
Filipino champ to secure a spot in the
grand final
there he faced Christine the heir to his
old unpopular defensive style this time
Chris was the heel as everyone wanted to
see him and his lame play style go down
oh my god we'll be crowning a new
champion
this might be it guys the King returned
as the mobile God has returned to his
throne
[Applause]
he's back he's back winner's bracket
little time the best piece is the best
that was the sickest thing I've ever
seen I think if anybody's gonna remember
something it's a lot of moments that
you're gonna remember of Justin but
that's gonna be my number one by taking
out Chris G Justin had redeemed himself
as the hero
RESA menteng his legacy as one of North
America's greatest fighting game players
but being the king of MVC again was
still not enough while he was playing
Street Fighter and Marvel Justin was
placing in major top eights in Dead or
Alive guilty gear killer instinct
Mortal Kombat Tekken King of Fighters
Tatsunoko vs. Capcom Soul Calibur pokken
Skullgirls and even divekick eventually
though the life of working full-time and
competing in tournaments wore him down
after signing with echo fox in 2017
Justin left his job at Nvidia to finally
go into eSports full-time he moved to
Las Vegas set up a gaming house and even
began using his money to start
sponsoring players it's been pretty fun
I would say I've been more like just out
of it in terms of like I don't have to
think as much like like to put my years
in
and I wanted to focus on this whole time
because how amazing FTC is growing and
like how so many people are interested
in justin hasn't stopped but he has
slowed down he finally broke his Street
Fighter capcom cup curse in 2017 and
didn't go Owen too but he still only
played 17 just be warm with all the
right reads on wakeup haitani was scared
of DP that he got hit with so many times
what a result for Justin won't he's
expressed interest in playing every
fighting game that comes out though from
Super Smash Bros to Dragon Ball fighters
a lot of the games out there they're
scenes like if Justin doesn't play it
like people don't think it's like you
know important
Justin Wong is living the eSports
version of the American dream he started
from nothing and worked day in and day
out to eke out a living dominating the
fgc was what he did in his spare time
he's the most decorated player in Evo
history with 24 Evo top eight medals
across 10 different games including nine
first-place trophies justin wong isn't
just dominant at marvel or good at
Capcom fighters he's fluent in fighting
games justin wong is perhaps an may's go
down just as the greatest fighting game
player from the US like ever
he could retire today and he doesn't
have to do anything for the rest of his
life that says a lot of God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button